we need to express this really small
number in scientific notation let's just
see how small it is it is one two three
four five six seven eight nine zeros and
then a three four five seven and all of
that is behind the decimal point now
this is a bit of review about scientific
notation
it means expressing a number in a form
where it's going to be some number you
know let me let me I'll just give an
example it could be say five times 10 to
the fifth power this would be an example
of writing something in scientific
notation and when you write something in
scientific notation the number that
you're multiplying by a power of 10 that
number right there has to be greater
than or equal to one and it should be
less than 10 and of course this right
here is going to be a power of 10 so for
example if I were to write 5 times 9 to
the fifth not scientific notation if I
were to write 50 times 10 to the fifth
not quite scientific notation sometimes
this kind of gets by for scientific
notation while you're doing computation
but if you really wanted to write this
in scientific notation
you would write this as 5 times 10 which
is 50 times 10 to the fifth and 10 times
10 to the fifth is 10 to the 6 so you'd
write this as 5 times 10 to the sixth so
your goal is always for this number
right here to be greater than or equal
to 1 less than 10
likewise point if I were 0.9 times times
10 squared once again not in scientific
notation you would want to write 0.9 as
9 times 10 to the negative 1 times 10
squared and then this becomes 9 times 10
which makes sense because 0.9 times 100
is 99 times 10 is honored we could say 9
times 10 to the first power so that was
a bit of review let's do it for this
problem right here so in order the I
guess a quick way to think about
converting this to scientific notation
think about how many leading zeros there
are including the first nonzero number
right there so there are 10 digits to
the right if you include
this three you have nine zeros and then
you have this three so a very quick way
to do it and I'll explain the second why
it works is we could rewrite this right
here as three point four five seven
times 10 to the and remember we had nine
zeros one two three four five six seven
eight nine and then I count the three
ten so times 10 to the negative 10 power
and the reason why this makes sense is
when you multiply something to a
negative power you're you you shift the
decimal over to the left so you're gonna
have to shift that this is essentially
saying let me write it this way
start with three point four five seven
start with three point four five seven
and when you multiply it times 10 to the
negative 10 you're going to shift the
decimal to the left 10 spaces so if you
shift the decimal to the tenth left 10
spaces what do you get so if you shift
it once twice three four five six seven
eight nine 10 and of course you can't
just leave open space here there's going
to be zeros there when you shift it so
they're gonna have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
zeros and you can put a 0 out here just
to make sure that you understand that
this is going to there's a zero in front
of that decimal and you get exactly what
we got up there another way another way
to think about it is if you wanted to
start with this really small number if
you wanted to start with this really
small number and you wanted to get to 3
point 4 5 7 you could multiply it by 10
to the 10th right that would take that
would shift this decimal 10 spaces to
the right so you could do this you could
say you could say that 3 point and these
are all the multiple ways of looking at
the exact same thing you could write
that 3 point 4 5 7 is equal to this
character or I could even copy and paste
this character is equal to this guy let
me copy and paste it copy and paste is
equal to that guy times
times times 10 to the 10th power right
if you multiply by a positive exponent
you're multiplying by 10 every time you
multiply by 10 it shifts the decimal to
the right it makes the number bigger so
if you take if you multiply this guy 10
to the 10th this guy's going to move 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 it would shift it right
there and you get 3 point 4 5 7 so
that's the whole idea that's through
this that that 3 point 4 5 7 is this
number times 10 to the 10th so if you
wanted to solve for this number you
would multiply both sides of this
equation by 10 to the negative 10 so
times 10 to the negative 10 or you
that's the equivalent of dividing by 10
to the 10th so 10 to the negative 10
times that right there these cancel out
10 to the 10 times 10 the negative 10 is
10 to the 0 or just 1 10 to the zeroth
power is just 1 and you get this thing
over here being equal to 3 point 4 5 7
times 10 to the negative 10 I just wrote
it in a different order over here